[Music]
this is a red abalone it's basically the
oceans version of a garden snail
it lives primarily on large rocks in the
lush kelp forests of California it has
also been a popular delicacy in the
state for over a century while wild red
abalone is not available to commercial
fishermen recreational abalone divers in
Northern California can snorkel down to
the rocks pry off a snail and bring it
home for a barbecue that is until
recently something is happening to the
kelp forests and it's threatening the
survival of the species
and the Northern California communities
that rely on the red abalone for
business in December of 2018 California
Fish and Game decided to close down the
recreational abalone fishery until 2021
in hopes that they might give this sea
snail population a chance to Reba my
name is Jo Cresselia I've been diving
since 1969 50 years the North California
coast is just an incredibly beautiful
place the typography the really high
cliffs and big rocks and stick out on
the water it's almost prehistoric in
that way you feel like you've really
gone off into another world
[Music]
we're catching up here or the red
abalone there's a variety of abalone but
red abalone traditionally is what your
grandparents would think of and they
were seeing abalone on the coast
for people they think they don't like
fish for people that don't think they
like selfish it's amazing to see their
eyes just Farkle and they take a bite a
look oh this is absolutely incredible
and you know before they took the bite
they were almost afraid to take a bite
in 1916 California established a
commercial fishery for wild red abalone
but in 1997 commercial fishery closed
due to a dwindling population twenty
years later at the recreational fishery
closed when purple sea urchins ravaged
the kelp forests and left the red
abalone dying of starvation
I appreciate what Fish & Game has done
and I think anybody intelligently does
and it's recently closing it down was
something I had predicted by watching
the ocean there was a couple places I'd
literally been diving for 50 years and
there really wasn't enough kelp you can
see it you would see the kelp stumps and
four or five sea urchins on it just
chomping it looked like someone had come
in with a chainsaw and just cut it
you're going down you're seeing like a
blanket of sea urchins the cult was
disappearing the abalone you weren't
seeing as many of because they were off
looking for food and there was an
unbalanced I were a dive watch that
gives me my depth and my water
temperature and I was noticing the water
temperature getting higher and I was
used to the water being 49:51 kind of in
that range sometimes she'd be in a
little cold it would be a little warmer
but I was seeing spikes where the water
was 54 or 55 degrees at times for 40
years and seen pretty much the same type
of temperature consistently and to see
those type of variances made me wonder
the bottoms changing there's no question
about it
and the and you can see olds abalone
shells broken stuff for everyone and
died
[Music]
so yeah
whose life's changed on the bottom now
it's going through going through a
change my name is dr. Laura Rogers
Bennett and I am a senior environmental
scientist here at the bodega Marine
Laboratory abalone are very much an
indicator of the health of the kelp
forests they are very sensitive to any
changes in food abundance they're not
able to switch over and eat meat and so
when their numbers go down we know
there's something going wrong in the
kelp forest
in 2013 we had a sea star wasting
disease that hit our coasts really hard
and that took out a lot of predatory sea
stars after that we had the warm blob
the El Nino of 2014 and 15 up in the
Gulf of Alaska there formed a warm water
blob and the oceanographers called it a
blob and so that warm water sat in a
patch and extended all the way down to
our region and that feature set up and
didn't move and just stayed there not
took out all of our kilt because the
water got too warm for our kelp to
survive studies done on the blob show
that while there were a number of
natural drivers that formed it
human-generated global warming likely
made it worse shortly after that we had
the purple urchin explosion of around
2015 and 16 they can mow down forests
like lawn mowers and they multiply very
quickly and they grow very quickly they
grow a lot quicker than species like
abalone so the abalone can't really keep
up with their eating habits the purple
urchin are taking the kelp before it can
even get to a mature age so they're
eating baby kelps before they can
reproduce and that's what's causing this
huge urgent barren that we've been
seeing
[Music]
usually in a healthy ecosystem a red
abalone would be hidden under a rock
lately we've been seeing them on top of
rocks and they're almost half to
three-quarters of their body are perched
up and they're just waiting for anything
to drift by and float into their muscle
or their mouth and so it's a little bit
of an odd sighting some divers have a
little bit of kelp they keep in their
pockets in case they pass a red abalone
and you can put kelp in front of an
abalone and it will lurch it's really
wild to watch it will actually lurch up
like a puppy dog that just smelled a
treat and it will almost unhinge its
whole body just to go grab that piece of
kelp and it tucks it in and it kind of
like holds it from all the other
merchants that are usually around it
we collected new numbers as of 2018 and
we don't see any improvement in the
abalone population if anything we saw
more declines
so we typically see around 24 to 26
thousand divers coming to dive and rock
pick and collect abalone but they're
also coming with a lot of their friends
and family it's estimated that the
recreational red abalone fishery is
worth about 44 million dollars to the
local communities and to the fishermen
who are participating in the fishery
Silver's at the wharf is a full-service
seafood and steak restaurant and 17
lodging rooms which are used principally
by fishermen my name is Jim Hurst and we
are in front of Silver's at the wars and
Noyo Harbor Fort Bragg California the
impact of the abalone closure is
somewhere about 30,000 to 40,000 dollars
a month that's attributed to lots of
food sales and lodging sales once you
lose that business you don't get it back
it's it's interesting to compare what's
going on today to when our mill closed
and when the mill closed everybody fat
oh my God we're gonna die that's it's
gonna have a huge impact it can't be
replaced my name is Chris Bryan's we're
here at harvest market I am a grocery
clerk I have worked here for 29 years
there is a large amount of people that
came to Fort Bragg to go diving it the
whole family would come April first
comes and goes now whereas before you
could see the influx of the people that
are going diving I think seeing and
understanding how interconnected
everything is being able to pick your
food out of the ocean like that you have
an appreciation for the effort that goes
into it and where it comes from
this isn't from some abstract store
someplace this is actually your
activities and you see how it grows and
there's a relationship it should be a
relationship of stewardship this is a
source of food and you want to protect
it
and you want to take care of it so that
you can continue to do it it's a
renewable resource as long as it's
properly handed as the globe warms we're
going to have more marine heat waves
we're going to have longer duration heat
waves and they're going to be broader
geographic extent and so I think this is
really giving us an inkling of what is
to come it's quite sad that these people
that have done this for generations have
to stop
[Music]
it's interesting recently I was talking
to some people and somebody made a
comment yeah nature's gonna heal itself
question is will man go along with it or
not or will he make the environment so
intolerable for itself that that'll be
it
I'd like the mankind will go on also and
be part of this
[Music]
[Music]